- [Instructor] We're told
that Darryl spent 24 1/4 hours
writing a chapter of a novel.
And then they ask us, what
are some things that 24 1/4
divided by 3/4 could
represent in this context?
So my understanding of this
is they really just want us
to be a little bit creative
about what division by a fraction
could represent in a given context.
So, well, one, I encourage
you to pause your video
and think about that a little
bit before I think about it.
But one thing I think about
is, well, if I took 24 1/4,
and if I were to divide it
into chunks of 3/4 of an hour
because this is in hours,
how many chunks would I have?
So this could represent,
let's say that he spent,
he spent 45 minutes,
which is the same thing of 3/4 of an hour,
3/4 hours, of an hour, I should say,
3/4 of an hour each day.
How many days, how many days
did it take him, did it take?
And then you could evaluate
this, 24 1/4 divided by 3/4.
We've talked about how to
evaluate that in other videos.
So that's one context.
Another one could be some
type of a comparison.
So let's say that 24 1/4
is 3/4 of the amount of time
that he spent doing something else.
So let's say, so this is now a
completely different context.
I'm gonna put a line here.
I'll do it in a different
color just to make it clear
it's a different context.
So another one could be to
justify doing this division,
he spent 3/4 as long writing,
writing as he spent illustrating,
illustrating the chapter.
And so then the question
is how long did he spend illustrating?
How long did he spend illustrating?
Now, I really want you
to think about this one.
My brain, actually, this one
takes a little bit longer
for my brain to process.
But when you think about it,
if you divide by a fraction
that is less than one,
you're gonna get a number larger
than the one that you're dealing with.
Or another way to think about it,
the time spent illustrating,
time illustrating,
I'll write it like this,
the time illustrating times 3/4
should be equal to the time spent writing
because it says he spent,
or he spent, I forgot to write that,
he spent 3/4 as long writing
as he spent illustrating.
So time illustrating times 3/4
should be time writing or 24 1/4.
So if something times
3/4 is equal to 24 1/4,
then 24 1/4 divided by 3/4
should be equal to time illustrating.
So these are the two
contexts that I can think of
that might make sense,
but you might be able to think of others.